I became a better coach because I  learned to zip it now and then because  you'd watch him play and all of a sudden  he would make a steal to win a game or  get an offensive rebound or shoot a  three that was totally contested the  worst shot in the world and it would go  in because he's a winner  so I had to learn to stop going to say  Manu  geez always what do we need that would  you why huh I am mother this is what I  do  that's it even telling me over and over  and then I look over at Tim or Tony and  they would just shrugged her shoulders  and we'd all just move on move on but  there the way the team was set up we all  needed each other and without mana there  were no championships there were no  championship